wait Rihanna gets tipsy with Seth Meyers
and its is everything are we going to
hold okay it's time for dinner it was so
the Rihanna the 31 year old singer was a
guest on Late Night with Seth when the
pair decided to take their interview
outside of the studio and into the bar
where they downed tequila shots chased
with beer that's more than enough
they also drank rum this is a drink
called under my umbrella
yeah and rye diamonds in the Rye it's
gonna have some rye whiskey okay cuz our
diamonds is a blue diamond almond milk I
don't even like know what don't you say
that every game and champagne I could do
whatever I want the pair got so tipsy
Seth asked to brief for some advice on
love and her response was cheeky AF I
want
it's like blow my wife away with like a
romantic night out what do I do
you said it what they also managed to
squeeze some time in for glam oh my god
you know what you're doing my burning
Rihanna may have taken the day off to
drink with Seth but she is one busy lady
building an empire she's now got her
fancy fashion line venti beauty line and
savage ex penty lingerie collection and
of course she always makes time to give
back with her Clara
Lionel Foundation I couldn't tell you
how happy excited on top of all of that
responsibility and bus ladyness re also
found time for love with billionaire
boyfriend Hasan Jamil
[Applause]
[Music]